Existe t'il des araignées qui se
nourrissent exclusivement de végétaux ?
Est-ce que certaines araignées pourraient aider les agriculteurs à se débarrasser de pucerons, insectes nuisibles ou autres prédateurs des plantes ?
Pendant combien de temps peuvent vivre les araignées selon les espèces sans boire ni manger ?
J'ai joué l'autre jour avec une araignée que j'ai bloquée, elle m'a mordue.
Enfin, m'a-t-elle mordue, m'a-t-elle pincée ?
J'ai eu mal, comme une piqûre de guêpe, quelques secondes et puis ça a disparu.
Il y avait venin ou pas venin ?
Je dirai, un centimètre de corps.
Dans le jardin, et rousse, plutôt rousse.
Parce que c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse.
Je ne voulais pas la tuer,
je voulais voir...
Est-ce que les araignées développent une adaptation vis à vis de vous ?
Vous parliez de certaines espèces protégées mais est-ce qu'il y a des espèces en voie de disparition ou en voie d'extinction ?
J'ai deux questions, je ne sais pas si j'ai le droit...
Quand vous avez dit que vous aviez fait une thèse sur les parasites des araignées
Ma question, c'est quels types de parasites vous avez étudiés ?
Et en outre des relations de type parasitisme, est-ce qu'il existe des relations symbiotiques avec des araignées ?